les états unis serait-il sur le point
d'imploser
une nouvelle vidéo d'une possible bavure
policière vient mettre le feu aux
poudres rendue publique par les
autorités de chicago ce jeudi les faits
remontent au 29 mars dernier elle y
montre un jeune adolescent adam toledo
courant poursuivi par les policiers le
jeune latino de 13 ans s'arrête puis
lève les mains sans armes apparentes
avant le coup de feu du policier nous
vivons dans une ville traumatisée par
une longue histoire de violences est de
mauvaise conduite de la police
alors bien que nous n'ayons pas assez
d'informations pour être le juge et le
jury de cette situation particulière il
est certainement compréhensible que tant
de nos résidents ressentent une vague
d'indignation et de douleur bien trop
familière mais encore une fois je
demande instamment je demande instamment
à chaque résident qui se soucie et aime
cette ville d'attendre jusqu'à ce que
nous entendions tous les faits white
l'ex agent toledo n'est pas le seul à
avoir été tué par la police américaine
cette semaine
ce dimanche le jeune afro-américain
d'interights a été abattu par une
policière dans la banlieue de
minneapolis lors d'un contrôle routier
la policière kim potter a assuré avoir
confondu son arme de service et son
pistolet électrique taser inculpé pour
homicide involontaire
elle encourt jusqu'à dix ans de prison
un drame qui a ravivé des fortes
tensions à minneapolis avec plusieurs
manifestations ces derniers jours et des
ertes entre protestataires et forces de
l'ordre
la seule question qui se pose à nous
aujourd'hui est de savoir si le nom de
danté white va rejoindre la liste des
afro américains qui ont été injustement
tué par la police qui n'ont pas obtenu
que la police soit tenu pour responsable
tant de nos enfants ont été tués par les
personnes qui sont censés les protéger
et les servir dans des situations très
suspecte est très controversée
cette nouvelle bavure policière met de
l'huile sur le feu à minneapolis ville
ou de charges floyd a été tué en mai
dernier et dont le procès de derek
chauvine accusé de son meurtre se
déroule actuellement
après plusieurs semaines de débats
l'ancien policier a invoqué ce jeudi son
droit au cinquième amendement de la
constitution américaine
monsieur nelson prend beaucoup de
décisions au cours du procès mais il ne
peut pas décider pour vous si vous aller
témoigner ou non et il peut vous donner
des conseils et vous pouvez suivre ces
conseils ou les rejeter mais la décision
finale doit être la vôtre et non la
sienne est votre décision de ne pas
témoigner lesueur de ce jeune c'est le
cas votre honneur le verdict du procès
de derrick chauvine prévue pour fin
avril est très attendue aux etats-unis
son dénouement pourrait avoir de lourdes
conséquences à travers le pays
si les policiers venaient à être
acquitté
beaucoup redoutent des débordements à la
hauteur des manifestations et des
émeutes
après la mort de georges floyd